all right let's get into this what are
natural units in order to understand
what natural units are we want to know
what are units so for example what is a
meter or if you're being Canadian a
meter I'm based in Toronto if that
wasn't clear already what is a second
what is a pound
now you'll get fairly frenzied if you
think about this for quite some time as
I have that is metaphysically what the
heck is a second what is a meter what is
length a science doesn't answer what is
questions it's operational science is
metaphysically agnostic meaning that it
doesn't actually make a claim onto
ontology it doesn't tell you what is
instead science gives operational
meanings so what is a second it says
here the second is equal to the duration
of nine one nine two six three one
periods of the radiation corresponding
to the transition between hyperfine
levels of the unperturbed ground state
of assisium atom a certain isotope of a
system atom
okay so then the natural question that
comes up is why this number
so why this and not some other number
and the reason is because in London many
decades ago someone in some back alley
took methamphetamine on a Tuesday night
and came up with that number now I'm not
kidding it may as well be that to
someone studying high energy physics in
the same way that
well what the heck is a kilogram what is
a kilogram it means you go to Paris you
go outside Paris actually it's on the
borders of Paris you go to some vault
and you deal with people being
condescending too because you don't
speak French then you duplicate this
little metal slab that's in Paris you
duplicate it 67 times so that you have
68 of them in total
I'm just being quick with my writing 68
of them is in total and then you measure
yourself on a scale and these two
numbers will coincide that's what it
means it's an operational definition now
physicists like to use units that appear
in nature so units that appear
and those we call Natural units there's
some controversy with what's considered
natural because when someone comes to
you with a
some dish and they say this is a natural
dish and that's unnatural well what do
you mean that that those Doritos that
are unnatural did they come from outside
this universe from some void because
it's in everything in this universe
natural aren't we a product of Nature
and so what we create is natural okay
what a physicist means by natural is
that it's invariants across the universe
as far as we can tell to be extremely
precise what we mean when we say natural
units natural in the natural units is
natural with respect to our current
understanding in order to make certain
equations simpler and remove arbitrary
human qualities
why do I say arbitrary human qualities
and not just human qualities well in
some sense even an electron is a human
construct in the sense that it's there
because it nature doesn't parse itself
out into these elements I mean you can
say elementary elementary seems to be an
objective quality because of the way
that we Define what an elementary
particle is it's an irreducible
representation of something so the fact
that it's irreducible means if it could
be reduced in this block Matrix form
then we can just decompose it and we'd
say those elements are Elementary but
the reason why we set aside some special
canonical place for the electron is
because it's useful for us it makes our
models easier to understand simpler
outcomes razor Etc there's plenty of
philosophy that undergirds natural this
is not usually explained and you'll be
led astray if you don't understand that
point now here's another Point that's
ordinarily not explained observables
[Music]
have
null units
there
[Music]
dimensionless
let's say slash ratios
Okay now what's meant by that again when
you say that you weigh 68 kilograms it
means you take 68 of some other
reference
quantity some other reference object and
then you stack 68 of them and then you
get yourself it's actually 68 it's not
68 kilograms per se you can also think
of this in another way if you wanted to
speak to aliens which by the way is
another topic on this channel not
speaking to aliens per se but UFOs then
it would be foolish to say I weigh 68 of
some product from France now you can
reverse this and imagine an alien is
speaking to you and you say well how
much does your craft weigh and they say
oh it weighs four garbars and then
you're like what the heck is a garvar
then they say well that's how much
liquid we release from our vorbins every
two farkles it doesn't provide much
information so instead we do what you
see colloquially which is C equals H bar
equals one okay let's get to some myths
about natural units before exploring
exactly what that means so firstly one
of the myths is that we just simply set
C to equal 1 to equal H bar this is a
meaningless statement as it's written
and the reason is it doesn't they can't
equal one it means we're now using
the speed of light and h-bar as a
reference for some other quantity that
we're trying to develop if you're
confused about this now then that means
you're thinking about this correctly
because it's not ordinarily explained
it's left ambiguous
let's look at this let's imagine what is
the speed of let's say some car on the
highway
so the speed of a car on a highway
equals we would say 100
kilometers
per hour
these are the units
and that's the magnitude with respect to
those units so if I wanted to say what
is the speed
sorry that's already speed what is the
speed of light
what we mean is two nine nine seven nine
two four five eight again it's one of
those numbers you try to show how clever
you are when you're a child by
memorizing meters per second
now look this is actually what C is C
refers to all of this C doesn't just
refer to the magnitude C refers to the
entirety of it including the units so
when someone says C equals one C equals
one what they actually mean is that we
are now using units where we've taken
that two nine nine seven nine two four
five eight meters per second and we've
placed it in here so we've taken this
guy and we've placed it in here see all
of this is not ordinarily explained and
it's because
as an undergraduate you're especially
used to writing with reference to a
coordinate basis which is why I said try
to do everything you can coordinate free
if you have an instructor you're lucky
enough to have an instructor you always
ask how can you represent these
equations coordinate free another way of
thinking about this is that we have
graphs in physics and math constantly
plot and those etchings are akin to
choosing a unit the fact that we put
lines with etchings means we've chosen a
coordinate so these etchings outward are
it implicitly a choice of coordinates
but nature but if you look again like I
mentioned that there's no detector that
can detect the coordinates much like if
you take a picture with your phone and
you then look at it on the screen and
you zoom in you see pixels the pixels
are an artifact of you taking a picture
and trying to manipulate it in some
manner the world itself is not pixelated
unless you're to believe Thomas Campbell
or Donald Hoffman another reason to
think coordinate free is you'll start to
construct constructions that actually
depend on your coordinates when they in
fact don't in nature and then you'll
wonder why are you getting an incorrect
answer so for example in physics and so
on we often use
let's see this and then we represent it
in some symmetry this is how theoretical
physicists generally reference matrices
they don't like them so they call them
symmetries these rows and columns but
then you also would reference this same
object
with numbers in a similar manner
however they transform completely
differently so one is an endomorphism
then the other is a two form or a
bilinear form and they transform
completely differently and which is why
you have transpose which is it's not an
ill-defined object but it's a strangely
defined object the inverse of a matrix
is more copacetic but the transpose is a
strange one so this one is a two form a
bilinear form the metric in the with the
Einstein equations is a 2 4 is a
bilinear form and also the determinants
of endomorphism is a completely
different object it's invariant compared
to the determinants of a two form or a
bilinear form and then as you start to
understand this coordinate free you'll
realize that there's a special place in
hell for the person who developed the
transpose it's an unwieldy object
another one that will confuse you if you
think in terms of coordinates is that
the wave function you ordinarily think
of the wave function that's going from
some Rd or some subset of Rd
to
to the complex numbers but actually this
guy is a section
on a c line bundle and you need to
understand bundles in order to
understand it coordinate free so that
you can do not only polar coordinates
and you wonder why the heck does the
derivative change well that makes sense
when you understand it in terms of a
principal bundle and then the associated
bundle but also in terms of no longer
staying in Rd what if you want to move
to a curved space for quantum mechanics
what if you want to do quantum mechanics
on a curved space this is why one should
try their best to understand what the
heck is going on without reference to
coordinates and then go to coordinates
when you're actually making a
calculation that's why this is a myth we
just simply set C to equal one to equal
H bar by the way what is h bar well
that's a bit more abstract you don't
need to understand that for the sake of
this video but this is an ill-defined
equation there's actually a caveat here
that will come into play later another
way of thinking about it is imagine you
have one USD one US dollar
sometimes you would say it equals 127
Yen it doesn't actually equal 127 Yen
otherwise when you have a US dollar it
would just be 127 Yen what it means is
that there's something called value or
some monetary equivalent that's another
way of thinking about it conversion what
it means that you go here with some
mapping let's say m and then here with
some mapping that's that's called let's
say m Prime
what it means is that you do
let's say m Prime
inverse see we have to make all these
constructions now and then that's after
you've already done M so you've gone
from here and then you go back up there
they're not the same so another way of
thinking about this is imagine you want
to change lengths instead of using
meters because you think meters are
strange for some reason you want to
measure everyone in terms of Lady Gaga
so you have Lady Gaga here which I'm
going to call
LG so now let's say we want to measure
someone else let's say some let's say
Goku so what is Goku Goku
equals maybe one and a half Lady Gaga's
in length so you take half of Lady Gaga
and you stack that again on Lady Gaga
and you get a Goku in terms of Link how
about Tony Robbins well that's let's say
two Lady Gaga's now what we're doing
here is we're saying I'm going to make
all my future length measurements in
terms of Lady Gaga for whatever reason
in the same way that generally speaking
prices can be made in reference to the
US dollar and then you do some
conversion to find out its equivalent
monetary value in some other currency in
the same way what we're doing right here
is we're referencing everyone's height
in terms of Lady Gaga's height and it
just as foolish as it would be to say
Lady Gaga equals one equals the USD just
as foolish as this equation is it's
tantamount to saying C equals one equals
H bar there's so much that goes into a
statement like that that's just seeing
that gives the impression oh physicists
are just setting it equal to one so no
this statement is foolish and what's
underneath that is saying hey I'm going
to now measure everything in terms of
the speed of light so I want to measure
my car maybe it's a millionth of the
speed of light I don't know I don't want
to do the calculation right now but
let's say it's a millionth of a speed of
light so then I say well the speed of
walking let's say
is
0.0005 I'm making this up of these speed
of light units that's what it means okay
so this is all including by the way this
right here this is all foolish
you have to understand what's lurking
underneath so in this example the value
is what's being referenced when I see
the real world that's what I mean is
that there's something else that's
tangible that I'm trying to represent my
quantity in reference to so from now on
we're going to no longer say that this
is moving at 500 meters per second we're
going to say that this is moving at a
fraction of the speed of light by the
way this should be a definition and that
refers to the entire object there not
just this this is just the magnitude and
that's where this is misleading because
it's just showing you the magnitude how
the heck can c equal this in the same
way how the heck can Lady Gaga equal the
US equals one that is myth number one
now myth number two is that the
advantage
welcome to the theories of everything
podcast you just watched a clip from a
much larger two hour video Lesson
including what to do with these natural
units such as how to calculate the
radius of a black hole in five seconds
no joke as well as the vacuum energy of
the universe as well as the pressure
inside a neutron star some facts about
extra dimensions and quantum gravity to
watch it click here and also this video
was sponsored by brilliant brilliant is
a website where you can go to learn math
science and engineering through these
bite-sized Interactive Learning
experiences I keep saying this on the
show and I mean it that at some point I
would like to speak to Chiara marletto
or David Deutsch on Constructor Theory
and that's heavily based in information
Theory and thus as preparation for that
I went through brillian's course on
information Theory and random variables
and from there I was able to finally see
why the formula for entropy is the way
that it is it's handed to you on high
from above and it looks Baroque and
highly manufactured but after going
through their course you can see that
it's an extremely organic choice for a
formula visit the link brilliant.org toe
to get 20 off your annual subscription I
personally recommend that you don't stop
before four lessons keep going even if
you feel like you're not making progress
on the first second or third go to four
and you'll be extremely surprised that
you can now Rock what you previously had
a difficult time grocking thank you